Hello,
thank you all for coming.
This is going to be a talk by my friend,
the journalist and science writer.
Uh,
Neil,
please silence your phones and on Google we can have some copies of the book for
you to take home if you're interested by what he has to say.
Neil and I worked together as software engineers more than 20 years ago in
Berkeley.
And,
uh,
we've been in touch but not nearly enough.
And he has had such a exciting career that went to the edge of physics,
one of his other books.
And uh,
yes,
please,
uh,
welcome,
Neil for his,
uh,
presenting his latest book.
It's just out.
[inaudible].
Yeah.
So thank you.
I know.
Oh,
for that introduction.
I know,
and I go back a long way.
Um,
I was a software engineer before I became a journalist and uh,
I,
it's really a pleasure to be speaking here at Google.
The last couple of times I came to speak where if I,
my previous two books,
uh,
which I really enjoyed the talks and the first one was called the edge of
physics and the second one was called the man who wasn't there.
And both of those books I was able to sort of tell stories about people and
places that I visited.
This book is somewhat different.
The protagonist of this book,
he's a single experiment.
It's an experiment with a 200 year old history.
Um,
and uh,
this book is really the story of quantum mechanics told through the lens of one
experiment and it's modern variations.
Um,
so it's a,
it's a slightly different kind of work in the sense that it's hard to tell a
stories in the way that I could have done with the previous two books.
So what I thought I'd do is I'll start by just reading a few pages,
uh,
just four or five pages from the book,
the opening four or five pages,
just to give you an idea of how a writer might want to think about opening a
book,
which is actually quite nerdy at some fundamental level because it really just
gets into the details of this one experiment,
but you still want to,
uh,
write it in a way that's appealing to almost anybody who wants to pick it up.
And then I have a,
a set of slides that I would like to,
uh,
go through just to,
just to tell you what this experiment is.
Most of you would be very familiar with this experiment.
It's called the double slit experiment.
Um,
but it's amazing how,
um,
how much this particular experiment pervades quantum mechanics.
So I want to run you through a few slides just to talk a little bit about,
uh,
what it tells us about the big conceptual issues in quantum mechanics.
Uh,
and then we can have a short Q and a.
So,
uh,
so if you don't mind,
I'm going to start reading from the book.
So this is the prologue,
the story of nature taunting us.
The office is simply the most uncluttered of any physicist office I've ever
seen.
There's a chair alongside a small table with nothing on it,
no books,
no papers,
no lamp,
no computer,
nothing.
A Sofa graces the office,
large windows overlook a small lake and the trees around which are bare except
for a few stragglers that were holding onto their fall foliage defying the
approaching winter in this part of Ontario,
Canada using hardy puts his laptop on the table pointing out that he does most
of his work in cafes and figures that all he needs in his office is a cafe like
small table to sit down his laptop.
There is the obligatorily blackboard taking up most of one wall of his office.
It doesn't take long for hardy to spring up and start chalking it up with
diagrams and equations.
Something that most of the quantum physicists I meet seem inclined to do.
We start talking about some esoteric aspect of quantum physics.
When he says,
when he stops and says,
I started off the wrong way to reset our discussion.
He says,
imagine you're a factory and they make bombs.
He has my attention.
He writes two names on the blackboard elixir and Weidman.
He's talking about something called the elixir vitamin bomb puzzle named after
two Israeli physicists.
The puzzle exemplifies the counter intuitive nature of the quantum world in ways
that non physicists can appreciate it confounds physicists to in no small
measure,
the problem goes something like this.
There's a factory that makes bombs equipped the triggers.
The triggers are so sensitive that a single particle,
any particle,
even a particle of light,
can set them off.
There's a big dilemma how the factory's Assembly nine is faulty.
It's churning out both good bombs with triggers and bad bombs without triggers.
Hardy rights hardly writes them as quote,
good and bad,
and quips about the quotation marks.
Obviously you may have a different moral perspective on it.
He says the task is to identify the good bones.
This means having to check whether the bombs have triggers,
but examining each bomb isn't the correct strategy because in order to do so,
you would need to shine light on it however faint and that would cause a good
bomb to explode.
The only ones unexploded would be the duds without triggers.
So how does one solve the problem?
If it helps,
we are allowed one concession.
We can detonate some bombs as long as we are left with some good on detonated
bombs from our everyday experience of how the world works.
This is an impossible problem to solve,
but the quantum world,
the world of very small things like molecules and atoms and electrons and
protons and photons behaves in bizarre ways.
The physics that governs the behavior of this microscopic world is called
quantum physics or quantum mechanics.
And we can use quantum physics to find good bombs without setting them off.
He went with a simple setup.
It's possible to salvage about half the good bombs hit involves using a modern
variation of a 200 year old experiment called the double slit experiment.
It was first done in the early 18 hundreds to challenge Isaac Newton's ideas
about the nature of light.
The experiment took center stage again in the early 20th century.
You went two of the founders of quantum physics,
Albert Einstein and Niels Bohr grappled with this revelations about the nature
of reality.
In the 1960s Richard Fineman extol his virtues,
saying that the double slit experiment contain all of the mysteries of the
quantum world.
A simpler and more elegant experience will be a simpler and more elegant
experiment would be hard to find.
The workings of which a high school student can grasp yet profound enough in its
implications to rebuild their brains like Einstein's and boards or confusion
that continues to this day.
This is the story of quantum mechanics from the perspective of one classic
experiment and it's subtle sophisticated variations including one that has,
we'll see Saul fell.
It's revisement bomb puzzle.
Whether these variations are carried out as thought experiments by luminous
minds or painstakingly performed in the basement lab.
So physics departments,
it's the story of nature taunting us.
Catch me if you can.
So I will read a couple of more pages from the opening chapter.
And this chapter actually begins by talking about a lecture that Richard Fineman
gave,
which is one of the most extraordinary lectures you can see.
It was given in 1964
and it became a very nice way to actually open the chapter just to talk about
what he was saying.
So chapter one,
the case of the experiment with two holes,
Richard Fineman explains to the central mystery.
Richard Fineman was still a year away from winning his Nobel prize and two
decades away from publishing and endearing autobiographical book that introduced
him to novices as a straight talking scientists interested in everything from
cracking saves to playing drums.
But in November,
1964 two students at Cornell University in Ithaca,
New York,
he was already a star and they received him.
As such,
Fineman came to deliver a series of lectures.
Strains are far about Cayuga's.
Waters rang out from the Cornell chimes,
the provost introduce Fineman as an instructor and physicist par excellence,
but also of course has an accomplished Bongo drummer.
Fineman strode onto the stage to the kind of applause reserved for performing
artists and opened his lecture.
With this observation.
It's odd,
but in the infrequent occasions when I have been called upon in a formal place
to play the Bongo drums,
the introducer never finds,
never seems to find it necessary to mention that I also do theoretical,
but his sixth lecture,
Fineman dispense with any preamble,
even a talk on hello to the clapping students and jump straight into our
intuition and jumped straight into how our intuition,
which is suited to dealing with everyday things that we can see and hear in
touch fails when it comes to understanding nature at very small scales and often
he said it's experiments that challenge our intuitive view of the world.
Then we see unexpected things.
So at Fineman we see things that are very far from what most.
We see things that are very far from what we could have imagined and so our
imagination is stretched to the utmost,
you said not as in fiction to imagine things which aren't really there,
but our imagination stretched to the utmost just to comprehend those things
which are there and it's this kind of situation that I want to talk about.
He said the lecture was about quantum mechanics,
the physics of a very small things in particular,
it was about the nature of light and Subatomic bits of matter such as electrons.
In other words,
it was about the nature of reality to light and electrons show wave like
behavior like water does or do they act like particles like grains of sand do
turns out that saying yes or no it would be both correct and incorrect.
Any attempt to visualize the behavior of the microscopic Subatomic entities make
some mockery offering tuition.
They behave in their own inimitable way,
said Feinman which technically could be called the quantum mechanical way.
They behave in a way that is nothing like you've ever seen before.
Your experience with things that you have seen before is inadequate,
is incomplete.
The behavior of things on a very tiny scale is simply different.
He said they do not behave just like particles.
They do not behave just like waves,
but at least light and electrons behave in exactly the same way.
So I'd find men that is their both screwy.
Fineman caution the audience that the lecture was going to be difficult because
it will challenge their wildly had views about how nature works.
But the difficulty really is psychological.
He said an exist in the perpetual torment.
The results from you're saying to yourself,
but how can it be like that,
which really is a reflection of an uncontrolled,
but I say utterly vein desire to see it.
In terms of some analogy with something familiar,
I will not describe it in terms of analogy,
analogy with something familiar.
He said,
I'll simply describe it.
And so to make his point over the course of an hour of spellbinding oratory,
Fineman focused on the one experiment which has been designed to contain all of
the mystery of quantum mechanics to put you up against the paradoxes and
mysteries and peculiarities of nature.
It was the double slit experiment.
It's difficult to imagine a simpler experiment or as we'll discover over the
course of this book,
one more confounding.
We start with a source of light place in front of the source or sheet of opaque
material with two narrow closely spaced slits or openings.
This creates two parts for the light to go through.
On the other side of this opaque sheet is a screen,
what would you expect to see on the screen?
So that's how the book begins.
And I think for the rest of the top,
I just want to run through the experiment and point out some of the big uh,
conceptual issues in quantum mechanics that this one simple experiment
addresses.
So this is the experiment that was first done 200 years ago.
There's a source of light is shining at an opaque sheet with two slits cut into
it and you're asked the question,
what would you expect to see on the other side?
Your infusion pretty much says,
oh,
I shouldn't just see two strips of light on the other side.
Actually the answer really depends on what you think is the nature of light.
And in the 17th century,
uh,
thanks to eyesight,
Newton,
our ideas about the nature of light,
we're really due to his corpuscular theory of light.
Newton said the light is made of corporate salts or particles.
So if,
if light is made of particles and if you're streaming,
uh,
you know,
a beam of particles,
at least two slits,
then that you expect a certain result to come out of this experiment.
So an intro,
thinking about light,
let's just for a moment,
just think about say particles that we understand.
Particles of sand for instance.
So this might be a sandblaster just blasting sand at these two slits.
So if,
uh,
say the right's leader's closed,
right?
What do you expect?
You expect to see the sign go through?
The left slid and hit the screen,
Eh,
you know,
it's right behind the open slit.
The same thing.
If the left third disclosed,
you expect to see the sign goes through the other slate not.
And you know,
uh,
the closed left slurred is obstructing the sign.
So basically you're seeing the particles hit the screen right behind the open
slit.
And if you were to now open boats,
slit,
our intuition tells us that this is what should happen,
right?
You should,
you should basically c two strips of,
uh,
particles hitting the screen on the back of the opaque screen.
This is not what happened when the experiment was first done in the early 18
hundreds by an English physicist called Thomas Young.
Uh,
he saw something completely different.
He saw this,
he saw
bands of light and dark appearing on the other side of the two slits.
So here,
think of the screen as a photographic plate.
So the dark bands are where most of the light is hitting.
And so it's a negative.
So the dark bands are where the light is hitting and you can see that there are
alternating dark and light bands.
So there's light,
there's no light,
there's light,
no light,
right?
This can only be explained if you think of light behaving like a wave.
So the wave hits the two slits and then from each slit to new sets of waves
start coming out.
This spread,
eventually they will interfere with each other.
And the places where these two sets of ways interfere constructively,
meaning the crests of a one way line up with the crest of the other.
You get constructive interference.
And when the,
and the trough a lineup,
you get destructive interference.
So essentially you get this interference pattern.
This is absolutely characteristic of waves.
You can see this,
uh,
you know,
anywhere you see waves,
for instance,
uh,
you know,
walk with water waves on a lake or in the ocean.
Now this idea that light behaves like a wave kind of held through pretty much
through the 19 hundreds,
uh,
sorry,
the 18 hundreds.
And then along came quantum mechanics.
Early 1900 Einstein was the first to point out that light.
There are certain situations in certain phenomena in nature,
particularly the photoelectric effect,
which is what he was talking about at the time,
can only be explained if you think of light as being made of particles.
So,
uh,
quantum mechanics is that all energy is quantize light as a form of energy.
And so light is made of individual in the indivisible Quanta,
uh,
of,
you know,
and these contact can be called particles of light.
Now this same experiment becomes incredibly,
uh,
confounding.
So if you go back to this,
now imagine that your source here is beaming,
say,
red laser light.
So light of one frequency.
And we now know from quantum mechanics that light,
uh,
is made of particles.
So,
so this is beaming out,
uh,
individual particles.
Now imagine also that you can turn down the intensity of this laser light to the
point that only one particle of light is coming out at a time.
Just one at a time,
maybe one every five seconds,
one every 10 seconds.
It doesn't matter.
But just one particle is going through that piraters at any given time.
And now what do you expect?
Now your intuition pretty much says that it should behave like particles of sand
because you know,
classically you're thinking it should go through one slit or the other and it
should end up on the photographic plate right behind the open slits and any
guess as to what happens.
This is quantum mechanics.
Obviously that's not going to happen.
Uh,
you get exactly the same result except that this is what starts building up.
If there is a photographic plate on the other side of the slits and if you're
sending one,
particularly at a time in the beginning it seems like the particles are randomly
going to,
you know,
uh,
look at certain locations on the,
on the plate.
But over time as the pattern develops,
you see that the same interference pattern develops.
Right?
This is again indicative of some interference that's going on except,
and this is something really important to appreciate.
You're creating a particle and you're detecting a single particle
and nothing,
you know,
even a single particle is going through the double set apart as he does not
interacting with any other particle.
There's just one particle in their pirate as at any given time.
So yet an interference pattern is emerging.
So what is interfering with what?
Right?
So this becomes a really important question to ask and,
and ends up being the central question in trying to understand some of the
conceptual issues with quantum mechanics.
So if,
if you are now shooting,
uh,
you know,
individual photons of say,
red light,
uh,
of a given frequency at this particular double slit,
then you get this interference pattern of the back,
which is exactly the same that you saw when there was lots of light going
through,
uh,
going through the double slit.
So the question is,
what is it that is interfering?
So mathematically there is an explanation.
So mathematically,
uh,
each photon or each particle of light is represented by what is,
is called away function.
It's a mathematical abstraction.
This way function is,
is,
is a function.
It's a function which tells you what it's value is at some point in space and
time and this function
evolves according to something called the Schrodinger equation.
So there is an equation that tells you how this way function changes with time
and mathematically.
The way you model this system is you let this way function propagate,
propagate towards the two slits.
It hits the two slots,
it acts exactly like a wave.
It goes through both slits on the other side.
You have two sets of waves coming out and they interfere and you get an
interference pattern,
but you're,
you're getting it in turf interference pattern of a mathematical abstraction,
right?
What is this way function?
What has his way function got to do with a single particle and that is really
the central issue that this particular experiment starts addressing.
So we can start asking what is it that's interfering?
There is,
there is a wave function that's going through the two slits and interfering and
creating a interference pattern on the other side.
But the wave function is a mathematical abstraction.
It for any system of more than two particles this way function doesn't even
exist in normal three dimensional space.
It exists in a mathematical space called configuration space.
It can have a large number of dimensions depending upon what your number of
particles are.
So what is actually going through the two slits and it's very,
very unclear as to what what is happening here.
So the wave function goes through the two slits,
a mathematical abstraction.
You can calculate what the interference pattern is on the other side,
and then the interference pattern tells you basically the value of the way
function at various points in space.
And you can then ask what is the value representing?
It turns out it's not really telling you where the Photon is aware of the
particle of light is the value of the wave function at any point in space is
only giving you the probability of being able to find the photon there if you
look for it.
So it turns out that the interference pattern created by the way functions,
there are many,
many regions where there is a nonzero probability for the photon to end up in.
So you have a single photon that is going through the two slits.
It's being represented by a wave function,
which essentially goes through two slits,
interferes on the other side.
And on the other side you have these various regions of constructive
interference,
which are,
which all have nonzero probability for the elect for the photon to end up in for
any given photon.
When you send it through the two slits,
there is no way to tell exactly where it will end up.
So it's non-deterministic,
right?
You've created a single photon.
It's somehow has gone through the two slits on,
on the other side,
it's going to end up in one of many locations which have a nonzero probability.
So this wave function is essentially a way to calculate what is the probability
of finding a photon in some location on the other side.
And it turns out that,
uh,
when you do a measurement,
in this case,
the photon interacting with your photographic plate is the measurement.
That measurement somehow collapses that wave function,
which until the measurement happened,
uh,
give you probabilities of the photon has possibly being in.
You know that off gave you probabilities of finding the photon in many different
places.
But the moment you do a measurement,
when the photon interacts,
when the wave function interacts with the photographic plate,
the way function collapses.
The photon is found in one place and not in any of the other places that it
could have been.
So this act of measurement kind of collapsing the wave function is a huge issue
in,
in quantum mechanics because quantum mechanics basically says that it's the
measurement that is causing the collapse of the wave function,
but it doesn't actually define what a measurement is.
A standard quantum mechanics just divides up the world into quantum systems that
are being measured and imperatives is that are measuring,
doing the measuring.
But there is no distinction mathematically speaking as to what constitutes a
quantum system and what constitutes a measuring classical or priorities.
There's also another mystery that this experiment highlights.
Now if you try to figure out which slit the photon is going through,
like your intuition is telling you,
not commander,
it's a single photon,
it has to go through one slit or the other and say you set up a system where you
can tell which slid the photon is going through without destroying the Futon,
then the interference problem disappears.
So if you try to look to see which slid the photon went through,
the interference pattern disappears.
If you don't look,
there's an interference pattern,
right?
So all of these things start meeting to questions about what is really happening
at that very,
very basic level of reality.
It's very clear intuitively that the photon can't possibly be going through both
slits at once,
right?
I mean you've created a single photon,
you've detected a single photon.
All your classical intuition is telling you it's surely it's not going through
both slits at once,
but something is going through both slits at once because you are getting an
interference pattern.
So,
so the is the way function going through both slits at once.
But then what is the way function?
The wave function is a mathematical abstraction.
We have no idea what that is.
It exists in some abstract configuration space and interferes.
But that's just mathematics.
We don't know if that is real.
So if that's not real,
then again,
the question comes back then what is going through both slits?
So this circular argument keeps going,
this idea of the wave function being real or not real,
whether it is actually representing something that is happening in reality in
the sense that it,
it represents something actual about reality is it's part of the ontology of the
world,
or is it just,
it,
does it just represent our knowledge about what's happening?
So it's the wave function,
authentic or ontological,
or is it epistemic?
These questions are yet undecided in quantum mechanics.
We really don't know the status of the wave function as to what that really is,
right?
So these kinds of that you can see there,
just this one simple experiment.
The moment you tried to understand what's happening,
it completely,
uh,
explored this whole business of what actually is the nature of reality.
I just want to run you through one very,
uh,
simple version,
a modern version of this double slit experiment.
It's called [inaudible] Zender interferometer.
And this will lead us to trying to answer the question about how do you detect
that bomb,
uh,
which had life triggers versus a bomb that had duds,
right?
So this is
the beginning of what's called a maximum under interferometer of photon or light
hits this thing called a beam splitter.
A beam splitter is simply a half silvered mirror.
Any window pane actually works like you can see if you look at the window pane,
some of the light is getting transmitted in,
some of it is getting reflected.
So if you imagine a laboratory grade beam splitter,
it's reflecting exactly half the and transmitting exactly half the late a half.
The energy of the light that's incident on this beam splitter goes one way.
Half of it goes the other way.
And that kind of works when you're thinking about a lot of light.
If you just take a,
you know,
a,
a flashlight and shine it at the beam splitter in PAF is reflected,
half is transmitted.
That makes sense.
But now remember it's quantum mechanics.
So you're allowed to talk about single particles of light.
So now what happens if a single particle of light is incident on this beam
splitter?
Now we know from quantum mechanics that the single particle of light cannot be
divided any further.
It is the quantum of energy.
It is the smallest quantum of energy.
So it turns out quantum mechanics is that the photon in this case will be
reflected with 50% probability and transmitted with 50% probability when it hits
a beam splitter.
So basically it's either going to be reflected or transmitted and for any given
for 20,
you can't tell what it will do.
But if you send thousands and thousands on average halfway you go one way,
half,
we'll go the other way,
right?
So we can now put detectors at the end of these paths and these detectors are
going to click half the time for,
uh,
the photon being reflected half the time for the photons transmitted,
right?
So we can now sort of make this a configuration a little bit bigger.
All.
All that this figure has done is it has turned the paths of the two beams are
dry tangles.
It's still the same.
A photon goes into the first beam splitter and then ends up either in Detector d
one or ends up in detector d two so if you were to send 10,000 photons into this
beam splitter,
one by one by one on average,
5,000 are going to be reflected.
5,000 are going to be transmitted.
It's five and a half the time the one we'll click half the time,
d two will click right?
This is a very,
you can do this in the lab.
This will happen all the time.
Here's what happens when you complete the marks and the interferometer.
Something very,
very intriguing happens.
If you put another bean splitter exactly at the place where the two beams cross
right now,
if,
if Dee one clicks,
right,
if you look at the previous figure it right,
if dyn clicks here,
if the detector Dijuan clicks,
it's very clear that the photon took the reflected,
but if d two clicks,
it's very clear that the photon took the transmitted path.
But in the full interferometer.
Now
the photon is reflected by refracted or transmitted by the first beam splitter,
and it also reflected and transmitted by the second beam splitter.
Now,
so if now d one clicks,
can you tell which path it took?
Any thoughts?
So there's no way to tell,
right?
I mean,
if Devin,
if Devin clicks the Photon,
could I've been reflected first and transmitted next or it could have been
transmitted first in reflected next,
right?
And now,
uh,
if you send say 5,000 photons into this one by one,
what do you expect?
If you do the numbers
previously,
remember we said half?
We'll,
if we send 5,000 into it,
2,500,
we'll go to d one,
we'll go to d two on average.
Uh,
we can't tell what any single photon will do,
but on average now,
what about this?
Now?
Yeah,
where else would they go?
Right.
Your class.
But this is quantum mechanics.
This is a loaded question already,
right?
Uh,
so who said all of it will go to don?
Yes.
So this is the weird part.
All of them will go to [inaudible]
and this very,
very simple device illustrates just how funky quantum mechanics is,
right?
What's happening here.
If you,
if you try to model mathematically what's happening here,
the wave function of the photon.
Remember some mathematical abstraction,
which we don't know whether it's real or not enters the first bring sweeter it.
Now part of it is going to be transmitted,
part of it is going to be reflected and it's going to continue on those two
parts.
And then at the second being sweeter,
each component,
the reflected component is again going to be reflected and transmitted.
The transmitted component is going to be again,
reflected and transmitted,
right?
So if you now look at d one d one is going to be the the combination in terms of
the way function.
We're not thinking of the 400 right now,
but we have to explain.
So if you did this experimentally,
if you just did this in the lab,
all of the photons are going to go to [inaudible] none.
We'll go to d two as long as the path between the two beam splitters is exactly
the same,
all of them will go to dyn.
None.
We go to d two and that's a really counter intuitive result that you need to
explain the mathematics explains it,
right?
So basically now you have to think in terms of the way function,
the way function has split into two the first beam splitter and then split into
two.
Again,
each component splits into two again.
And then on the way to d one there are two components of the wave function that
are recombining and on the way to d to the two components of recombining.
But it turns out that when you're going towards d one the two components of the
wave function,
one which has been reflected and then transmit it and the other which has been
transmitted and then reflected,
remember we're talking a waves,
even though when in mathematical space these waves are in phase because they
haven't,
they have endured the same amount of reflection and transmission.
So they're actually in phase.
So these two waves mathematically are,
you know,
they are in phase and they constructively interfere.
Whereas the waves that are going towards d two uh,
has endured to reflections in two transmissions.
So one component is lagging the other in face by one 80 decrees,
the crests of one way or lining up with the trough.
That's destructive interference.
So in that mathematical configuration space,
the way functions have interfered so that all of the stuff is going to d one and
none is going to d two but remember this is happening in abstract mathematical
space,
but this is representing the photon.
So the photon always goes to d one none.
We'll go to d two and you can mess with these numbers by changing the lens of
the paths between the two beans leaders.
But for now,
if you think of them as equal,
then d one represents constructive interference d to represent destructive
interference.
No photon would go to d two right?
This does not make classical logical sense,
but it,
that's how the quantum world works.
And you can only explain this if you're thinking in terms of the way function
and what's happening to the wave function.
Right?
Uh,
but the question remained,
what is the status of the wave function?
Is it real?
Right?
So if you,
for instance now put a block in one of these arms,
what do you think will happen now?
Let's say we send 5,004 tons into the first beam splitter,
but there's a block in one of them,
one of the arms,
what do you think might happen?
Sorry,
half and half.
But what happens to the numbers?
So you sent 5,000 into the,
so it turns out that the block will cut down the number of photons by half,
but now w the function that is,
so it's cutting down the wave function component that's going along one path.
So nothing is going to progress along that path.
The way function that goes on the other path is now hitting the second beam
splitter.
But now if there's no interference because nothing coming from the other side.
So now it's just acting like before it,
half of it goes one way.
Half of it goes the other way.
So if you send 5,000 euros,
half will go to d one half of you go to d two but half of two 5,000 so 2,500 are
blocked.
The other 2,500 we'll hit the second gleaned sputter and then go half on one
half of the way.
This is now showing you that there's no interference.
Putting that block is very,
is analogous to trying to see which way the photon is going.
Right in the double slit.
If you blocked one of the slits,
this is analogous to that.
You're basically saying I'm blocking one of the slits.
I know now that the photon has to go through the other slate.
Well,
it,
yeah,
it does go through the other slip and there's no interference.
In this case it becomes a very clear demonstration of the lack of interference.
When you block one slip,
you open word slits.
Certainly all the photons will go to Dee Dee one.
None of them will go to d two.
Right?
So this is showing you interference or what other,
this is showing you the photons particle like behavior.
It's acting like a particle.
There's no interference.
But the moment you remove that block moment,
you don't try to see which part the photon is taking.
The system seems to behave like a wave and you get interference.
So now I want to sort of talk about how this simple thing can help you solve the
elixir vitamin bomb puzzle.
So to,
to,
uh,
let me just tell you about the bomb puzzle again.
What was the question?
The question is there's a factory that's making bombs,
uh,
and these bombs are triggered through extremely sensitive,
so sensitive that even a single particle of light falling on it will detonate
the bomb.
The problem is that the factory is also producing duds bombs without triggers,
right?
So your task is to figure out which bombs have sensitive functioning triggers
and which are the duds.
Now,
in our classical way of thinking about this problem,
if you were to look at the bom to see if it has a trigger,
it'll explode.
Because looking in walls,
shining light or something,
you'll have to use some energy to look at it.
And so,
you know,
even a single photon will detonate the bomb.
So there's no way classically in our classical way of thinking,
no way to solve this problem.
But you can solve this problem.
You can find out,
you can distinguish the dots from the live bombs using this Marcus,
under interferometer,
you're allowed to detonate some bombs.
So can you now,
so what happened?
Now say I have placed this bomb.
There's assume that all of this is being done in a dark room with robots and
you're not worried about blowing up the bombs because of handling them.
So let's assume that we can place the one right next to one path and this one
doesn't have a trigger.
And now you start sending in photons to this,
through this.
Apart as to this interferometer,
what do you expect?
So 10,000 photons are going in,
or do you expect
where,
where would the photons go?
Okay.
There's no difference between the previous,
you know,
there's no difference between this and this because the bomb was just sitting
there and the it has no trigger.
There's no obstruction,
right?
So this should just behave like a regular marks under interferometer.
All of the photon should end up at d one non non should go to d two.
Right?
So you really can't tell anything at this point.
Uh,
so let's say you did,
you know,
you're,
you're trying to do this within a statistical sense.
You say,
I'm going to send a million photons into this,
which you can do in labs.
These,
this very quickly,
all of them will go to d one.
None.
We'll go to d two.
That's a very,
very good indication that you haven't done next to interferometer.
Now,
if you have a live bomb,
right?
Life meaning a trigger that will actually,
it's plays to sorta little obstructs the photon path.
Now what happens now you start sending in one 41 at a time.
Yeah.
So this,
this trigger now his,
like the block that we put earlier,
right?
Remember there was,
uh,
we,
we had,
uh,
we had this set up where if we put a block,
that block is going to obstruct half the photons.
So this trigger now is like that block.
Half the time the photons are going to hit this block and half the time the bomb
is going to detonate.
So it'll blow up,
blow the bomb,
the bomb will blow up.
So will the Max under interferometer,
you'd have to rebuild it.
A zoom.
We can do all that.
This is a thought experiment so you can do all this.
Okay.
So half the time the whole setup will blow up the other half of the time.
It's interesting part,
the other half of the time the wave function is going through the other side,
right?
It's,
it's going through the other side.
He hits the second beam splitter and then what happens?
Yes.
So in this case,
half the photons will end up in d two,
right?
So if you send 5,004 tons in 2,500 of them on average will blow up the whole
thing.
The other 2,500 will get split up at the second half of them will go to d two
and half of them will go to d one if they go to d one it's kind of inconclusive
because you know the one was happening previously also.
But if any photon ends up in d two that's a sign that there's a live bomb in the
other path.
But here's the interesting thing.
You haven't interacted with the light bulb because if you had interacted with
the light bomb,
it would have blown up.
No,
but if,
if,
if it goes to d two you know there's a live bomb,
you can just pick that up and say,
okay,
this is what we're going to ship now.
Right?
Building half the bonds and quarter of them are short.
Yeah,
you can work out the probability.
So this is the bare minimum and you can,
you can fine tune this experiment to improve that.
Right.
But the idea here is something very,
very profound that quantum mechanics has allowed you to detect the presence of
something without interacting with it.
These are called interaction free measurements.
It does not happen in classical physics.
You cannot measure something without interacting with it.
Here we have physically interact with physically is a different truck.
Some interaction,
something has interacted with the bomb.
The photon hasn't because otherwise the bomb would have exploded.
Right?
But something interacted with the bomb and we got information about the one
without actually blowing it up.
So this is an interaction free measurement.
This is,
this makes the case for the reality of the wave function as if the wave function
is the probably the way function that is sensing
the bomb.
Right?
This argument can go round and round and round.
Yeah.
That makes me think of the Heisenberg uncertainty principle,
right?
Heisenberg uncertainty principle.
Very much.
We will come back to questions.
So why don't we just wait for the queen.
I'll just finish up and then we'll come back.
I,
in fact,
I just talk about that principle,
so,
okay.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean this is,
this is an example of how this,
you know,
this is a very special case of the double slit experiment.
This is the experiment that is done in labs on optical benchers.
It's very,
very easy to configure and work with.
And much of,
when physicists say that they're doing a double slit experiment these days,
they're more often than not building a magazine,
the interferometer and working with it.
And there are variations of this in many forms and,
and it's amazing how this one simple experiment allows you to understand some of
the very,
very basic issues in quantum mechanics.
Like superposition.
Superposition is this idea that we just talked about,
that the photon can end up being in two parts at once.
It doesn't make any sense.
So it,
there's a mathematical,
uh,
is sort of,
you know,
mathematical way of representing it.
The way of talking about it is to say that the photon is in a superposition of
taking both parts.
It's not the same as taking,
it's not the same as saying the photon is actually taking both parts.
It's just a way of saying that the quantum states are such that hit behaves as
if it is taking both paths.
So it's,
it's the way function that's taking both parts,
but we don't know what the ontological status of the wave function is.
So it's not the same as saying the photon is taking both paths.
The uncertainty principle,
right?
This,
these experiments allow you to,
um,
talk about the uncertainty principle,
which is the simple idea that there are certain parameters in quantum mechanics
in,
in particular the position and momentum of a particle.
You cannot measure both,
uh,
sort of accurately.
If you measure one very accurately the you mess up the other one.
So the more precisely you measure the position of a particle,
the more uncertain the momentum and vice versa.
So that's the uncertainty principle.
There's complementarity or wave particle duality.
Complimentarity being the idea that nature has two phases,
the wave nature and particle nature,
uh,
and you can only absorb one or the other.
And what you observed depends on the parameters that you've built.
So we saw that there were different configurations of that interferometer that
you can build,
which will either show you the particle nature or the wave nature,
but you can't see both at the same time.
Determinism versus non-determinism,
we,
uh,
classical physics is deterministic.
So,
you know,
if you throw a ball and you know all the forces that are acting on it,
uh,
you can predict exactly where it will go and uh,
and the trajectory of the ball.
Whereas here,
when you're talking of a photon going through the double slit,
you can only talk in terms of probably it is,
you can only assign probabilities to where it'll end up.
There is no clear trajectory that you can map out that the photon takes and,
and you,
and basically this whole system is non deterministic and you can talk about
determinism versus non-determinism in the context of the double slit experiment.
The biggest problem really is this thing called the collapse of the wave
function.
Remember the way function goes through both slits interferes and on the other
side you get this way.
We think that tells you mathematically what are the chances of finding the
photon here versus here versus here.
So,
and if you did a measurement,
it'll end up in one of those places until you did a measurement.
The probabilities existed in this,
uh,
in this wave function.
But the moment you do the measurement,
the wave function collapses and peaks at one point.
The problem with these go to zero everywhere and become,
it becomes one at the point where it's measured,
uh,
or where it's found.
So,
and there is nothing in quantum mechanics that tells you what this collapse
really is.
It's just,
it's a postulate.
It's a postulate is an axiom in quantum mechanics that says when you do a
measurement,
the wave function collapses.
We don't know the,
you know,
what the wave function really is in terms of its reality.
We don't know what the actual process of collapses and this thing is called the
measurement problem.
The idea that measurement causes collapse without being able to define what a
measurement really is is the cause of many,
many conceptual problems within quantum mechanics.
And a lot of the alternatives to standard quantum mechanics that you hear about
are alternatives that are trying to solve the measurement problem.
Uh,
there's realism versus non realism realism being this idea that there is an
objective reality that exists independent of observation that you don't need to
be observing in order to know that there is a reality out there.
Quantum mechanics,
at least the standard way of thinking about quantum mechanics questions that the
photon in this case doesn't have a reality until you observe it because there is
nothing in the mathematics that captures the trajectory of the photon from the
source to the detector.
That is,
you know,
you cannot,
you cannot calculate the trajectory.
He could end up,
we could have five different trajectories or any number of trajectories that
there's no way to tell.
The only reality ascribed to the photon is at the point of creation handed the
point of observation.
Right?
So in one way of thinking of our standard quantum mechanics,
it actually denies reality until observation.
So it is an observer dependent,
a theoretical framework.
I mean there are lots of
issues with this.
People debate this endlessly over and over again as to as that word is really
saying.
But one way of interpreting standard quantum mechanics is to say there is
anterior list.
Um,
then the questions about the wave function,
which I just told you about.
Is it really something that exists or is it representative of something that
actually exists or is it just our knowledge,
half-baked knowledge about what's happening,
right?
Is it epistemic or is it on tape?
I haven't even touched upon the other big issue in quantum mechanics,
but the double slit experiment allows you to talk about that also,
which has to do with entanglement or nonlocality.
The idea that if there are two quantum systems that are,
uh,
that have somehow interacted at some point,
once they've interacted,
they are now represented by the same way function.
And this way function starts spreading,
which means that maybe the particles are going apart and if you do a measurement
on one particle,
you can instantly influence the state of the other particle even if these things
are kilometers apart.
And that cuts against,
uh,
the idea of locality,
which is the bedrock of relativity,
which is the idea that what you do in one region of spacetime cannot influence
something else,
uh,
in another region of space time any faster than the speed of light.
Quantum mechanics apparently,
uh,
suggest that there is instantaneous influence.
Action in one region can instantly influenced the state of some other system,
uh,
and faster than the speed of light.
So again,
there are debates about whether that's really what it's saying,
but there's enough proof that that the underlying quantum reality is indeed
nonlocal.
Okay.
And the double seat and its variations.
I just showed you one,
the magazine,
the interferometer,
there are many,
many experiments that have been done that play on this principle.
There's the wheelers delayed choice experiment.
I don't think we have time to go through any,
I just named them.
And when you see them,
you'll realize when you see them in literature elsewhere,
you realize that these are all variations of the double set,
the quantum razor experiment,
delay,
choice quantum.
It is the interaction free measurements we just talked about.
There are experiments that have actually tried to measure particle trajectories.
I actually told you just now that you can't talk about trajectories in Spenard
quantum mechanics,
but there are other interpretations,
other quantum formalisms that allow you to talk of trajectories and there are
ways in which you can measure them and they're very controversial.
But nonetheless you can do double slit experiments where you can map these
trajectories,
you can probe the divide between the quantum and the classical.
Is is the world of quantum all the way through or is there some divide where the
quantum world gives away to the classical world?
We don't know the answer to that yet.
And there are a whole range of other things you can do that probe sort of
conceptual issues in quantum mechanics all using the double slit experiment.
And,
and my entire book is basically an exploration of how this double slit
experiment has been used for all these purposes.
And I talk about,
uh,
five particular five interpretations,
the Copenhagen Interpretation,
which is a standard quantum mechanics interpreted in by the people who started
in Copenhagen,
Niels Bohr and
Heisenberg and uh,
and a whole bunch of other people who've kind of polio.
All these people were involved in,
uh,
an interpretation,
which is now called the Copenhagen interpretation.
There's the de Broglie Bohm interpretation,
which is a very different view of the quantum world,
which basically says the quantum world is both a wave and the particle,
I don't think we have time to go into the details.
There are collapsed series.
So I talked about how the collapse happens because of measurement and it puts
observers at the center of everything.
But there are theories which removed the observer.
They basically cause collapse stochastically and then lead to the same
predictions.
And then there are people who take the wave function really seriously.
They basically say that the wave function splits and never collapses.
And each splitting wave function is,
has given rise to a different world.
So essentially every time a photon go through a beam splitter and goes left and
goes right,
you have created two universities,
one universe in which the four don went left,
one photon in which it at one universe in which it went right and so on.
So,
and then there's something about quantum Bayesianism,
which is actually quite a complicated one to discuss here,
you know,
easily.
But anyway,
these are the interpretations are dealing with in the book.
Um,
so yeah,
I think I'll stop here and take questions.
I hope that was informative.
Thank you.
Much of what you spoke about.
I think,
uh,
the,
the kind of questions that were raised with poverty,
I don't even probably say back in the fifties or sixties.
Yeah,
yeah.
What has happened since then?
A good question.
Um,
so since the mid thirties,
you know,
19,
late,
late 19,
20 [inaudible] and early 1930,
it was when the standard formulation of quantum mechanics,
uh,
well I got formulated.
So,
uh,
people like mainly due to,
one Ironman,
uh,
Paul Dirac and others,
you know,
so the standard quantum mechanics that exists is basically due to them that by
mid thirties was pretty much custom stone.
And then,
but you know,
these conceptual issues,
like you say,
have been around,
I mean,
they were around even before 1950s.
Einstein was arguing against these things throughout his career in quantum
mechanics.
Remember,
he's one of the founders of quantum mechanics,
even though people don't,
you know,
people ascribe to him his greatest achievements are usually thought of as,
the theories of relativity.
He is one of the founders of quantum mechanics.
And he had serious issues with these sort of questions that were raised just
now.
They haven't been solved.
So they issues remain.
The,
the amazing thing about standard quantum mechanics is it is extremely
successful.
These probabilistic predictions,
this,
this mathematical framework that is used to make problems,
he prediction is the most,
uh,
successful physical theory.
We,
I mean,
everything,
like,
you know,
all of the stuff that is happening right now with the electronics is happening
because that theory works right.
Uh,
but nonetheless,
he raises fundamental questions about the nature of reality.
We don't know.
And so 1950 was the beginning of,
uh,
you know,
David booms ideas.
1951 was when he came up with this,
uh,
Boomi and mechanics,
but that has a precursor,
it goes back to de Broglie in 1927.
So the theory now is called de Broglie Bohm where you have a particle which has
got been guided by a wave.
And the way it is real in,
in Bermuda mechanics,
except that again,
it doesn't move in three d space.
It moves in this mathematical configuration space.
But in Bowman and mechanics,
it is ascribed reality.
It is part of the ontology of the universe,
right?
And,
and some,
somewhere in the 1980s collapsed theories came about.
So this idea that,
you know,
the way function can collapse spontaneously stochastically without observers,
without measurement.
And so the,
and then there's Penrose,
Roger Penrose,
his ideas,
which I didn't touch it touch upon.
Um,
it's not really mainstream,
but he has some very interesting ideas about why gravity needs to be brought
into the mix.
So when you have two masters in super position of being here and here,
his argument is that these two masses will curve spacetime differently.
And then the two curvature of space time,
we'll also be in super position of being in,
you know,
in two different curvatures and that's unstable.
And He created,
he figures out a reason,
you know,
uh,
sort of,
he admitted himself that it's kind of rough calculations,
but this instability of the two configurations of Space Time will lead to a
spontaneous collapse,
right?
And of course,
small particles will take forever to collapse,
but as something larger,
like a cat will collapse immediately to either one or the other.
Um,
then,
um,
then there's quantum Bayesianism,
which is very recent,
last 10,
15 years.
So yeah,
so it's happening.
The point is that these issues are not resolved because all of these
formulations or interpretations make exactly the same predictions.
They have to make the same predictions in order to Talley with experiments.
Right?
So right now,
experimentally,
you cannot distinguish between these formulations.
So Boomi and mechanics and standard quantum mechanics make exactly the same
predictions,
but they have very different view of what the underlying reality is.
Anyone else,
I guess I'm following up on that or any of these interpretations like testable
or are they,
are they always just going to be pure guesses?
Like I mean at this point,
uh,
one our guesses right there,
they are a mathematical fit there.
They're trying to so balmy and mechanics for instance,
uh,
the underlying reality is considered to be particles that are being guided by
waves.
These waves are considered real except the waves move in configuration space and
uh,
and uh,
it's,
it's kind of,
it's forming the mathematics is formulated to make exactly the same predictions
that standard quantum mechanics because otherwise it wouldn't be a valid theory.
So right now there's no way to distinguish between standard quantum mechanics
and Boomi and mechanics.
Standard quantum mechanics has the other advantage that it has actually been,
um,
you know,
pushed along if,
it has been combined with special relativity to become quantum field theory and
so on.
It's much,
it's pulling much harder to do that with Boomi and mechanics.
So there are other issues that happen with these different interpretations that
can lead to people believing in them or not believing in them.
But right now,
uh,
I don't want to call it a matter of faith.
I mean it is the,
it is solid mathematics and all of these things,
but they're not in particularly distinguishable.
Excellent for collapse.
Series.
Collapse is do make a prediction.
They,
they,
they predict where the quantum classical divide lies.
So the collapse series basically point out that if the mass of the system that
you're looking at gets beyond a certain point,
it will spontaneously collapse within a certain timeframe.
And so now you can imagine doing the double slit experiment with larger and
larger entities.
So starting with electrons,
you can then go to atoms,
molecules to see if you get the interference pattern right.
And the moment the interference pattern disappears,
it means that the quantum object that you're sending through the double slit has
collapsed to in such a way that is only going through one or the other.
And it's not interfering anymore.
So those experiments are being done.
They have actually managed to send see 60 molecules,
60 carbon atoms through this double slit.
He didn't a few years.
The largest a molecule that has been sent so far through a double slit has I
think 800 items or 10,000 atomic mass units.
These are massive molecules and they will go to the double slit and interfere.
They behave as if they were going through both.
So the quantum classical boundary has not yet been seen,
but collapse series do make predictions that are not quite within reach of
experiments,
but maybe another five,
10 years.
Thank you.
We should take further questions after giving people a chance to leave.
There are copies of the book available if you would like to pick one up on the
way out.
No,
thank you very much.
Thank you.